which I didn't see the niqab in did
yong-joon yeah for the day so today
we're gonna be trying something unique
we're going to shoot an entire video
that's only either in first person view
or third person view and the two views
are battling each other rather than
having to figure out cool camera angles
all that kind of stuff the camera is
always tied to a character doing an
action which makes things a little
interesting now should be pretty cool we
got ya some parkour guys from Tempest
Freerunning we have some guys from
action factory we have some friends that
we play ourselves with richard ryan from
related our-our and we have d from node
2 of the most tactical guides we know
but this is actually a video we've been
wanting to do for a really long time if
you guys probably have seen one of our
old videos called the mini boss that was
a video we shot entirely in third person
and it was inspired directly from
Splinter Cell time to begin it's almost
11 o'clock and we gotta be out here by
sundown Steve this is a munitions plant
and these mercenaries have hired for
security to make sure that these deals
go off without a hitch they're over here
someone relaxed they have a motion
detector up at the terminal there's
nothing really to worry about
there hasn't been any action for a while
so standing around guys cleaning his gun
the guys looking at his gear making sure
it's working don't worry about delivery
too much we're going to be redoubling
all this stuff we're seeing it all go
pros all the audio be done later post in
the video it's gonna look like I'm going
like this with the gun like this
bringing it up and aiming in reality I'm
just going to be kind of aiming it up
inside I'm going to turn my head and I'm
going to let the camera naturally line
up with the sight that way I'll get that
like quick snappy motion for like
pulling the gun up but in reality I'm
just going to be moving my head over
like two inches to meet the gun instead
she I don't know if it's if I'm like
this and you swing at me once and I only
go down on then you swing at me again
and then you know that's when I do
these deals or whatever it might be know
she can be like shoo well hey I'll be
pretty sweet
I didn't get hit a couple times yeah
that's fine
yeah I think the whole idea is that um I
saw that first swing like guys knife
looks like that it's the guy either in
the arm or in the knees or in the ribs
and let me just hear crunch and markets
a pretty solid yet because the after
that happens the spies like he's
stumbled yeah that's alright I need to
say me so I could do more so I'm going
to go tell him to do that Sam were you
running look at me he's moving too far
out this way doesn't matter you got all
your left look back you got a break here
point a block going to do from forwards
I gotta break it down what's up guys I'm
D I work for a node I'm helping out Sam
and Nico on this shoot I'm doubling as
mercenary number two and tactical
overseer for the video I'm just making
sure everyone is addressed properly make
sure they have the right gear right
magazines right guns a lot of things
have been filmed here for one inception
was filmed here which is pretty sweet
this is also the same warehouse that
they shot episode 2 of ultimate gamer
deputy ultimate gamer which Wells on
they blindfolded us when they drove is
here so I didn't know where it was but
now I know where it is
[Applause]
you want to cross the brain it's a solid
[ __ ] sense
[Music]
know what causes the brain some passing
mind curls Jacob thought you put this
guy
[Music]
we are the guys who come in and get
awesome aerial shots how's it going I'm
Taylor and this is John and we are a
company called copter X based out of Los
Angeles and we basically fly the DGI
s800 finish me this is on a 3 axis
gimbal here it's all brushless motors
basically this is the 800 for a little
bit more professional applications and
then they have the new DJI phantom with
the GoPro zenmuse Hero 3d coming out
which is going to be sold on drone fly
calm so basically John is the pilot to
man operators to men operator over here
I got my little screen here this way I
can see what's going on from the ground
when the helicopter is up in the air a
lot of you have seen the new movie
gimbal coming out from free fly and this
is basically the same technology that's
been developed over a year ago year and
half go two years ago probably even
longer turn this way
look this beautiful sunset on the LA
skyline corridor digital boosts what
dreams are made of man is the YouTube
dream right here I'm living I live a
little risky
right right guys that's cool you looking
for stuff with you guys step drones
we're losing light accent
okay so when you check this to you again
some more things gonna come down all
right you just sneak up from behind it
obviously keep your hands away from the
cops but here grab these two you don't
need to do enter your scribe you got you
can do that and just know it when we go
away one is it comes into your hand make
sure you you grab it like no matter what
you can overpower the
[Music]
like something like that you want that
or yourself a little more yeah cool yeah
looks good alright guys here we go get
ready and action
[Music]
I didn't even I couldn't even really see
the cash yeah and this area we want you
to kind of wait until it's going up into
the air so that we have like more
activity on the brother back here
alright so it'll be gracious looked up
you'll see so basically pulling up
revealing more spies than both laters
thank you yep oh I guess at the very end
what's your high up eating panoply stick
and it'll be like LA and there's just
one over here a lot
sweet are you guys ready yeah alright
and three two one action
alright keep moving
[Music]
[Music]
so hardcore my name is Rin the Reaper I
make cooking videos and do makeup
tutorials and should check it out
sometime are you trying to plug me oh
well I guess I should quit being a jerk
about it and be like hey guys i'm
richard ryan from rated-r thanks for
checking out the behind the scenes of
the corridor digital Splinter Cell
blacklist parkow or our Jessi over here
with a bloody nose is that from is that
from snorting all the asbestos it is
what happens I just I needed enough
sorry I've laid out some pixie stick you
know the little sugar and then no from
the asbestos probably gonna die by the
end of tonight might be anthrax on the
way I'm at my chair bestest quote that
[Music]
yeah bro try to always stay weird on the
on the level of him so as you can starts
coming up and on this side start rising
up with them okay and if you can swim
[Music]
[Music]
I was a really good day that was it
there's no reason to do it guys that's
it kick the tires and light the fires
Big Daddy Wow
oh hello you caught us cleaning upset
because we're finally done we expected
to be done at 7:30 and it's truly 11:40
yeah so I don't know a couple extra
hours but everyone seemed to enjoy it
because we've got some cool pieces and
no pizzas people chill Peto they're warm
they arrived for yeah it's nice work Sam
likewise alright camera time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]